I have someone here who wants to say
something to April could she come say
something you Sandra Bullock is giving
back in a big way with the help of her
eight-year-old daughter Laila up there
as if something's - a - April thank you
viii go for doing everything for the
everything for everyone on Friday the
actress appeared on a special Mother's
Day edition of read Table Talk
there's a very special woman who wants
to meet you
me Amaya the episode was jam-packed with
sweet surprises for heroes fighting the
coronavirus and sandy was on hand to
surprise April a mom of two and nurse
manager in Los Angeles and what makes
this surprise extra special back in
April the actress donated 6000 n95 masks
to health care workers at the Children's
Hospital in LA the same hospital that
April works at April thank you for
trying to say this out crying thank you
for everything that you're doing the 55
year olds got emotional fighting back
tears as she thanked April for being on
the front lines we get to sit here and
be home with our family yeah because you
are out there doing the hard hard
absolutely and and I think it's Sandra's
boyfriend Brian Randall was the first to
share the news about her donation
revealing that her kids Layla and
ten-year-old Louie
actually came up with the idea you put
masks on the kids with gloves and rolled
on down there and deposited so they
could see firsthand the the first
responders and see how hard it is right
now and that's when Sandra's little girl
made a special appearance to send her
love - April - thank you eight go for
doing everything for the everything for
everyone
and hearts melted faith see she does
she's uh she's our world superhero she's
the one that's gonna save the world in
our family so she's ready she's ready to
join you out there April in a few years
the Will and Jada Smith Family
Foundation also donated $50,000 to the
same hospital and they're sending
April's whole family on a vacation when
the timing is right they wanted to do
something for you personally yeah you
know just for your service this is the
feel-good stuff we need right now I love
it I love it
thank you read Table Talk thank you next
time I see you when this is all over I'm
gonna give you big hugs a big kiss and a
big tequila laila blowing kisses at the
camera too cute
it makes me so happy so proud Sandra
adopted Louie back in 2010 and Layla
in 2015 and in 2018 she told et's she
always wanted to be a mom I would have
been pregnant I would've been knocked up
at 17 and my mother knew that and she
kept me under lock and key I wanted to
be a mom at a very young age that same
year she explained to ET how having
Louie and Layla changed her whole
perspective on life you look back in
your life you know I've had a really
good life but once you have children you
go my life was nothing until you showed
up
I'm you know it's wasting time literally
wasting time every day until they showed
up and now I know exactly what my life
is about because it ever
[Music]